je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui est ce
que quelqu'un a vu l'émission mots
croisés sur france 2 il ya quelques il
ya deux jours du juste 2 est-ce que vous
avez un commentaire à faire sur non pas
moi ils sont surtout sur comment est ce
que vous êtes comment est ce que vous
avez perçu la manière d'appréhender le
problème de des deux responsables
politiques qui étaient là et du de la
personne de l'ufc
avant avant même sa est ce que est ce
que vous êtes et ce que vous avez un
avis quand vous les voyez parler sur
leur degré de connaissance sur le
problème lui-même
ils connaissent moyennement où on sait
même pas s'ils connaissent contenu des
questions qui leur sont posées
pardon oui vous connaissez florence
foresti
il ya de ces sketches dans lequel limite
un ministre en disant je vais voter une
subvention de 15 euros / etc et je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué au moment où
il a parlé des voitures il a fait
exactement ça dure j'ai dû m'en cacher
derrière son plateau parce que il a dit
et grâce au système de bonus malus on a
réussi à la diminuer les ventes de
voitures qui font plus de 1,20 g de co2
par kilomètre vous êtes en manque et ça
c'est drôle
donc non il a les chiffres il les
connaît pas je peux vous le dire il y
avait un de ses conseillers qui lui
avait préparé une note qu'il avait
apprise dans la voiture en a en arrivant
et il est qu'il les connaissait
probablement pas plus que ça non je
voulais juste attirer votre attention
sur le fait que dans ce genre de
créneaux finalement on ne demande à
personne ni moi ni les autres de
produire ses lettres de créance pour
vérifier qu'on a affaire à des gens qui
savent de quoi ils parlent
voilà c'est juste ça que je voulais
faire remarquer donc peut-être qu'ils
savent peut-être qu'ils savent pas c'est
pas ça le critère de sélection pour pour
arriver là aujourd'hui on va donc parler
de là c'est peut-être un tout petit peu
lumineux sa non pour le pour le
vous voyez bien là c'est pas trop clair
ainsi en baisse à lumière vous allez
vous endormir mais
il y a
quand
à
c'est quoi ça
parfait
oh non ça va
ça va être bon là
c'est mieux donc aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler du du système climatique et
donc on va comme la dernière fois
reprendre l'histoire d'avant l'avait
laissé je vous avais dit en fait que ce
qui faisait la transition entre la
contrainte amont et la contrainte aval
c'était que finalement en décidant dans
les limites de ce qui est physiquement
possible de l'endroit où on veut mettre
la barre haut niveau de la contrainte
amont on va partiellement décidé
toujours dans les limites de ce qui est
possible de l'endroit où on va mettre la
barre en ce qui concerne la contrainte à
bâle donc ce que je vous avais dit la
dernière fois c'est que si en gros on
veut limiter le réchauffement planétaire
plutôt à 2 à 2 ou 3 degrés que 4 6 ou
plus
eh bien ça veut dire que il faut aller
très rapidement vers un monde sans
charbon et s'interdire d'extraire du sol
plus que ce qu'il y a comme gaz et comme
pétrole dans les réserves prouvées
voilà une fois je vous ai dit ça je vous
ai à peu près tout dit vous voyez qu'il
ya des séries historiques parfaitement
documenté sur le relèvement des
températures alors plus sérieusement on
va donc maintenant parler de climat et
on va commencer par quelque chose qui au
niveau d'études vous êtes devrait
normalement vous être accessible et
jeudi normalement vous être accessible
parce qu'on est absolument stupéfait par
le nombre de gens qui ont fait des déçus
d'à peu près similaire qui continue à
faire cette confusion le climat et la
météo c'est pas la même chose ça
s'apprécie avec des grandeurs qui sont
les mêmes mais ça ne s'apprécient
absolument pas sur les mêmes échelles de
temps et l'espace
donc le climat et la météo dans les deux
cas de figure on va parler de
température on va parler de
précipitation on va parler nébulosité on
va parler devant etc
sauf que dans un cas c'est instantané et
locales et dans l'autre cas c'est des
moyennes et les variations de cette
moyenne sur des espaces géographiques
plus large et des échelles de temps plus
longue
voilà donc s'il ya toute la différence
entre climat et météo qui lie à entre
votre note à une composition données et
la moyenne tout élève confondues des
compositions ici sur 30 ans et vous
voyez très bien que l'on peut avoir
l'une des deux grandeurs qui varient
dans un sens sans que ça de 10 heures
un sur la note d'un élève particulier à
une composition particulière donc quand
n'importe qui vous dit le climat ne peut
pas se réchauffer ou ne pas se refroidir
comme le disait allègre cette émission
dont je parlais parce qu'il a neigé en
chine l'année dernière
on est en train de confondre la moyenne
et la valeur isolé ça ferait exactement
ça qu'on est en train de faire vous
pouvez très bien vous prendre un plomb
dans un contexte dans lequel la moyenne
aux ventes absolument pas interdit du
réseau mais fait l'expérience donc le
donc le climat change parce qu'une
moyenne savary sauf que par construction
même une moyenne fluctue moins
rapidement que les valeurs isolé qui la
composent la variabilité sur la moyenne
est toujours plus faible que la
variabilité sur la mesure isolée donc c
est ça c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument majeur parce que c'est une
confusion qui est permanente et en
particulier dans le discours médiatique
autour de ce genre de sujet c'est
quelque chose qui revient sans cesse
mais alors un nom sans cesse ça
s'explique aussi gens commencent à
rentrer un petit peu dans le dur par le
fait que le climat peut être soumis à
des tapes cause de variation dont l'une
et nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais ça n'est pas la seule ces causes de
variation est long ce qu'on appelle des
échelles de temps caractéristique c'est
à dire qu'il ya des durées en année qui
correspondent au temps qu'il faut
attendre d'une certaine manière pour
aller aux résultats il existe par
exemple des variations des paramètres
astronomiques de la terre ce que vous
avez ici donc la terre les paramètres
astronomiques de la terre varie l'orbité
de la terre se déforme légèrement au
cours du temps sous l'effet de
l'attraction des grosses planètes du
système solaire comme jupiter et saturne
et bien on n'est pas juste dans un
système à deux cores avec la terre qui
fait une belle ellipses autour du soleil
qui ne varie pas il ya des petites
perturbations alors beat delà de la
planète donc l'excentricité de l'ellipse
varie au cours du temps et puis l' axe
de rotation de la terre s'incline plus
ou moins sur le plan de l'orbité et puis
la terre présente alternativement
l'hémisphère nord et l'hémisphère sud
quand elle est au plus près du soleil
dont cantal et au périgée
avec une espèce de périodicité de
l'ordre de 13 mille ans pour passer de
l'un d'eux plutôt 26 pour passer de l'un
à l'autre
donc vous avez des causes de variations
de l'orbité terrestre qui à l'échelle de
la centaine de milliers d'années ici
vous avez une échelle logarithmique la
des échelles de temps caractéristiques à
l'échelle de la centaine de milliers
d'années c'est ce facteur là qui domine
tous les autres donc à l'échelle de la
centaine de milliers d'années pendant
l'ère quaternaire c'est les variations
de l'orbité terrestre qui ont écrasé
entre guillemets toutes les autres
causes de variation du système
climatique et c'est ça qui a provoqué en
particulier d'alternance glaciaires et
interglaciaires après à des échelles de
temps qu'ils peuvent aller du million
d'années au milliard d'années vous avez
la tectonique des plaques qui influe sur
le système climatique puisque en
fonction de l'endroit où se trouvent les
terres émergées et donc par exemple à
neige en hiver quand il y en a un aux
moyennes et hautes latitudes
eh bien vous avez un albédo qui changent
en fonction de l'endroit où se trouvent
les terres émergées vous avez vous
n'avez pas des déserts et les déserts
ont aussi un albédo qui est plutôt
relativement élevé et donc ça ça change
le système climatique parce que ça
change la fraction de l'énergie solaire
que le système conserve pour fonctionner
et la tectonique des plaques forme
également le relief et elle formaient et
elle est également à l'origine du
volcanisme
alors ça par contre c'est des variations
du climat qui s'applique à des échelles
de temps qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
courte quand vous avez une éruption
majeure titre krakatoa et bien vous avez
une répercussion sur le système
climatique planétaire dans l'année où
les années qui suivent parce que vous
avez des injections massives de
poussière dans la stratosphère et sas a
obscurci un tout petit peu
l'illumination du soleil et ça modifie
le climat sur des échelles de temps
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus courts ce que
millions d'années bien évidemment après
vous avez les oscillations dans les
compartiments fluide et semi fluide de
l'atmosphère donc fluide seo et hertz
omis fluide c'est les gas et ça ceux des
causes de variation du système
climatique qui sont absolument majeur à
l'échelle du siècle au millénaire ce qui
domine le comportement du système
climatique à l'échelle du siècle au
millénaire c'est pas l'atmosphère c'est
l'océan ce qui soit dit en passant
signifie qu' il n'est pas nécessaire
d'avoir cerné la variabilité de
l'atmosphère à l'échelle de la cun
deux jours en d'autres termes il n'est
pas nécessaire de savoir quel temps il
fera dans quinze jours quelque part pour
être capable de dire des choses
pertinentes sur la variation lent du
système climatique à l'échelle du siècle
c'est pas nécessaire et enfin vous avez
vous bien évidemment est la seule
question qui aujourd'hui est posée à la
communauté scientifique n'est pas est-ce
que l'homme est responsable du
changement climatique
donc si vous pensez que la question ait
formulé comme ça après vous pourrez
faire un bouquin 250 pages en disant
c'est n'importe quoi et vous aurez
raison puisque la question n'est pas
formulée comme ça la question allait
formuler de la manière suivante c'est
est ce que l'homme est en train de
devenir la cause dominante de variation
du système à l'échelle du siècle
et si oui où est ce que ça peut nous
emmener c'est ça la question qui est
posée
jamais personne dans la communauté
scientifique là aussi je veux bien
parier quelques bouteilles de champagne
n'importe quel de laquelle d'entre vous
dans cette salle que vous ne me
trouverez pas un article scientifique
dans lequel la question libéré avec
l'expression est ce que l'homme est
responsable du changement climatique
jamais nulle part je vous disais tout à
l'heure quand on confond sans cesse
météo et climat ou sur ce petit
graphique en fait la météo c'est
l'examen du système à l'échelle de la
semaine où la journée est à ce moment
vous voyez que l'intersection à cette
échelle de temps de cette ligne
verticales ne concerne qu'un seul
compartiment du système c'est
l'atmosphère
donc en gros pour être capable de savoir
comment le système évolue à l'échelle de
la journée ou de la semaine
il suffit de s'intéresser à la variation
de ce qui se passe dans l'atmosphère
tout le reste pouvant être considérés
comme constant à partir du moment où
vous vous intéressez à l'évolution du
climat
maintenant vous voyez qui a des tas
d'autres trucs qui se mettent à
intervenir le soleil le volcanisme
l'évolution de l'océan nous l'évolution
de l'atmosphère et c est à ce moment
évidemment la question est de savoir
qu'est-ce qui va dominer là dedans
comment est-ce que ce système qui est
asservi dans tous les sens va se
comporter quand vous commencez à
tripoter de manière significative une de
ses composantes de manière naturelle
donc sans forçage humains anthropique
c'est clairement la variabilité de
l'océan qui domine à cette échelle de
temps un prêt car voilà donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut bien garder en
mémoire c'est cette différence
absolument fondamental qu'il y as entre
variations locales et de courtes
échelles de temps du système et
variations lente et à de longues échelle
de temps du système
j'ai pas besoin de savoir où est-ce que
vous dormirez dans trois semaines pour
être capable de dire des choses sur quel
genre de métier vous ferez en étant
statistiquement correct dans dix ans
j'en ai pas besoin
c'est un élément qui n'entrait pas en
ligne de compte c'est très important
pour savoir où dormir dans trois
semaines ça c'est clair ça n'a pas
d'incidence sur ce que vous allez faire
comme métier dans dix ans
statistiquement bon voilà c'est
exactement pareil
la variabilité atmosphérique à l'échelle
de la semaine n'a pas d'incidence sur la
manière dont le système va se comporter
à l'échelle du siècle pas d'incidence
alors je vais maintenant vous montrer un
petit dessin animé qui a été fait par
les producteurs de champagne qui ont
d'immenses qualités y compris celle de
faire des dessins animés pour essayer de
vous faire comprendre de quoi on parle
quand on parle de l'effet de serre et du
changement climatique
vous avez ici sur cette petite animation
de magna
ne veut pas de moi
un technique c'est dur
pardon ça flashe non mais là c'est le
format du c'est le format de l'écran qui
reconnaît plus là donc je vais essayer
de lui mettre autre chose
voilà
voilà donc je disais là je vais vous
montrer quelque chose qui est une
représentation schématique du
fonctionnement de la basse couche de
l'atmosphère sur cette petite animation
vous avez donc figurer avec la flèche
jaune le rayonnement qui nous parlait du
soleil qui est composée pour une petite
moitié de rayonnement situé dans le
visible pour une pour à peu près 40% de
rayonnement situé dans la fin aux
proches
donc il ya déjà une large partie du
rayonnement solaire que nous recevons
qui est de l'infrarouge et pour à peu
près 10% d'ultraviolets dont une
fraction significative est arrêté dans
la haute atmosphère par les molécules
d'eau jaune
tu ne constitue pas une couche mais qui
sont simplement un gaz présent à une
concentration suffisante pour être
capable d'intercepter pour être capable
de rendre l'atmosphère suffisamment
opaque aux ultraviolets
c'est pas comme une couche de neige avec
un début et une fin comme on pourrait
l'imaginer avec ce terme médiatiquement
impropre donc vous avez ici donc
l'énergie qui nous parvient du soleil et
vous allez figurer en bas la surface
planétaire avec une partie océanique et
une partie terrestre
vous avez figurer les nuages de
l'atmosphère immédiatement à droite de
la petite flèche noire le rayonnement
solaire qui arrive au sommet de la côte
faire il va lui arriver des fortunes
diverses à peu près un tiers va être
réfléchie soit par les nuages soit par
la surface terrestre et au sein de la
surface terrestre ce qui est
particulièrement réfléchissant c'est
tout ce qui est blanc ou quasi blanc
donc les carottes les surfaces enneigées
des moyennes latitudes l'hiver et les
déserts c'est ça qui réfléchit
l'essentiel du rayonnement solaire
et puis une petite fraction et réfléchie
par le reste et quelques pour cent sont
absorbés par l'atmosphère quand vous
avez un chauffage par le haut j'avais à
dire et à peu près la moitié est
absorbée par le sol donc en gros 50 %
par le sol 33% et réfléchie et le sol
est absorbée par l'atmosphère dont une
large partie des ultras violets dans les
hautes couches l'énergie absorbée par le
sol va évidemment réchauffé ce dernier
et vous savez que tous les systèmes
physiques adore
exactement comme les comptes des
sociétés cotées être à l'équilibré c'est
à dire se mettre dans une situation dans
laquelle il restitue autant d'énergie
qu'ils en ont reçu donc la surface
planétaire quand elle est à l'équilibré
thermique et bien c'est très exactement
ce qui lui arrive
elle va restituer autant d'énergie que
ce qu'elle en a reçu alors l a3 manière
de restituer de l'énergie la première
manière et de la chaleur sensible la
chaleur de contact c'est donc là l'air
qui passe au contact de la surface
terrestre qui est directement chauffé
par cette dernière
après vous avez une deuxième manière de
restituer l'énergie alors là on le voit
très mal sur cette animation s'est un
peu trop clair c'est l'évaporation de
l'eau qui elle permet de consommer de la
chaleur latente et la condensation de
cette vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère
restitue à ce moment l'énergie dans
l'atmosphère et puis vous avez une
troisième manière que le sol à de
restituer de l'énergie c'est de rayonner
d'infrarouge c'est de l'infrarouge de
grandes longueurs d'onde
donc pas de l'infrarouge identique à
celui qu'on a reçue du soleil de
l'infrarouge proche parce que la surface
du soleil état civil calvin
comme vous pouvez le constater la
surface terrestre juste un peu plus
froide donc les infrarouges émis par la
surface de la planète sont des enfants
ou de grandes longueurs d'onde
et il se trouve que l'atmosphère possède
un certain nombre de molécules en son
sein qui ont des raies d'absorption dans
les infrarouges de grandes longueurs
d'onde
ces molécules qui ont des raids
absorption dans les infrarouges de
grandes longueurs d'onde s'appelle des
gaz à effet de serre c'est très
exactement ça les gaz à effet de serre
c'est des molécules qui ont erré la
fraction dans les enfants rouges grandes
gueules vous voyez que dans ce système
le sol un restituer de l'énergie de
trois manières et ses trois manières
conduisent toutes les trois à
communiquer cette énergie à l'atmosphère
ou bien on la chose directement par
contact ou bien dans la chauffe par
évaporation condensation ou bien on la
chauffe en lui faisant absorber les
infrarouges de grandes longueurs d'onde
qui ont été émis par la surface même
motif même punition l'atmosphère reçoit
de l'énergie le système a cherché à
s'équilibrer et donc à restituer autant
d'énergie qu'il en a absorbé quand il
est à l'équilibré thermique alors
l'atmosphère elle elle n'a qu'un seul
moyen à sa disposition pour restituer de
l'énergie c'est de rayonner de
l'infrarouge
voilà s'est pas évaporé l'eau qui
allierait condensé on ne sait pas où
donc tout ce qu'elle peut faire c'est
réglé d'infrarouge elles vont rayonner
dans tous les sens à toutes les
altitudes dans des gammes de longueurs
d'onde variés et cetera en fait vous
avez des systèmes en cascade c'est à
dire qu'une molécule va rayonner de
l'infrarouge qui va partir vers le haut
qui va être absorbée par une nouvelle
molécule qui va être serré puis tout ça
tout ça se termine en chaleur d'une
certaine manière dont vous avez un
gradient thermique est ce cette
infrarouge qui rayonnait dans tous les
sens et c'est si vous en faites une
intégration
si vous cherchez à calculer la
résultante est bien vous vous retrouvez
avec un terme qui s'échappe vers
l'espace après avoir filtré à travers
l'atmosphère plus un terme qui passe
directement à travers l'atmosphère donc
c'est du rayonnement qui partie de la
surface n'a été intercepté par aucune
molécule avant de se retrouver dans
l'espace
et bien ce qui filtre à travers
l'atmosphère plus ce qui passe
directement par la fenêtre atmosphérique
ajoutée aux rayonnements réfléchi va
équilibrer le rayonnement incident donc
en gros vous retrouver dans un système
dans lequel vous avez un terme sortant
qui ajoutait au terme réfléchit enfin à
terme sur un terme sortant pour
l'infrarouge qui a agité ou qui parlent
en ajouter aux thermes réfléchi dans le
visible va équilibrer le rayonnement
incidences que le système a cherché à se
mettre à léquilibre l'espace mais par
contre vous avez récupéré dans cette
affaire interne supplémentaire de
chauffage du sol
vous avez aussi une résultante qui
retourne au sol et 7 résultante qui
retourne au sol en termes de flux est à
peu près identique aux flux que nous
envoie le soleil en direct le soleil en
direct nous envoie en gros de 130 watts
par mètre carré moyennées sur la surface
de la planète et sur toute l'année le
flux infrarouge qu'on va recevoir de
l'atmosphère et du même ordre de
grandeur
il s'agit aussi de quelques centaines de
watts par mètre carré en moyenne
annuelle et géographique donc l'effet de
serre est un truc qui est extrêmement
puissant ça met en jeu des quantités
d'énergie extrêmement puissante et vous
allez voir un peu plus tard que ça n'est
pas quelque chose qui est propre à la
terre ça c'est ce qui se passe avant
l'apparition des hommes gilles effet de
serre vous en avez survécu sous n'a pas
de rome vous en aviez sur la terre avant
que les hommes
donc la question de l'effet de serre
n'est pas la présence humaine par contre
la présence humaine va modifier la
composition chimique de l'atmosphère
en l'enrichissant en gaz à effet de
serre donc on est en train en ce moment
et on a commencé il ya deux siècles de
modifier la composition de l'atmosphère
vous montrerez après comment ça se passe
et ce faisant on l'enrichît en espèces
chimiques qui sont capables
d'intercepter les infrarouges terrestre
ce qui se passe à ce moment vous allez
devinez tout seul à partir du moment où
je demande dans les basses couches de
l'atmosphère là le pourcentage de
molécules qui sont capables
d'intercepter les infrarouges terrestre
ça veut dire que je vais empêché de plus
en plus fortement le rayonnement toutes
choses égales par ailleurs le
raisonnement le rayonnement infrarouge
de diffuser vers l'espace et je vais
augmenter le terme qui retourne au sol
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
alors en fait les choses ne restent pas
égales par ailleurs comme j'augmente le
rayonnement qui retourne au sol
j'augmenterais température d' équilibre
de ce dernier et comme job manta
température d' équilibre du sol eh bien
je vais augmenter tout les restitutions
d'énergie qui croise avec la température
y compris le flux infrarouge émis par la
surface pas des terres est en fait ce
fut va augmenter jusqu'au moment où le
système va atteindre de nouveau un état
d'équilibré avec l'attraction de ce flux
qui diffuse vers l'espace qui va se
retrouver identique à ce que j'avais
avant d'avoir perturbé le système mais
dans cette affaire j'ai intensifié tous
les flux d'énergie qui ont lieu entre le
sol et les basses couches de
l'atmosphère
c'est à dire à la fois les échanges par
rayonnement mais aussi mais aussi les
échanges par contacts et les échanges
par évaporation condensation suis désolé
ça paraît très mal sur ce graphique
donc j'ai intensifié ces trois flux des
échanges entre la surface des terres et
les basses couches de l'atmosphère
dès le moment où je vous dis que j'en
pense ici le flux évaporation
condensation vous comprenez que le
réchauffement climatique va rendre le
cycle de l'eau plus actifs dès ce moment
là je voulais des le moment que je vous
dis que l'évaporation va s'intensifier
et le chauffage par le bas de
l'atmosphère va s'intensifier je vous ai
dit que la conviction tous les
mouvements convectifs à l'aide
potentiellement s'intensifier donc dès
le moment où je vous dis ça se pose la
question de savoir ce que deviennent les
horizons
les orages les ouragans les tornades les
enfin absolument tout ce qui met en jeu
à mouvements convectifs dans
l'atmosphère c'est quelque chose c'est
une question qui se pose parfaitement
légitimement dès lors que vous avez
compris que cette affaire intensifie
globalement l'évaporation et le
chauffage par le bas donc voilà brossé à
très grands traits la physique
d'ensemble du réchauffement climatique
dont vous allez voir dans pas très
longtemps que ça fait un petit moment
que on sait à peu près à quoi s'en tenir
et beaucoup plus longtemps que le début
que l'avènement de la télévision
le point d'interrogation qui est là sur
le nuage rappelle que les nuages ou deux
effets antagonistes dans le système le
premier effet c'est que ayant un albédo
très élevé il contribue une manière très
efficace à la réflexion de la lumière
solaire et ça c'est un effet qui
refroidit la surface pas des terrains
qui lui diminuer son approvisionnement
en énergie solaire
ce que vous constatez les jours il ya
des nuages mais par ailleurs comme ils
sont composés de vapeur d'eau et d'eau
sous forme de gouttelettes et de vapeur
d'eau ils contribuent à l'effet de serre
car le premier gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère c'est la vapeur d'eau 1
l'espèce qui contribuent à la plus
grande fraction du rayonnement retourner
au sol dans cette affaire c'est la wagon
alors quand je dis qu'ils contribuent au
rayonnement retourner vers le sol c'est
bien évidemment le résultat de deux
caractéristiques un les raies
d'absorption d'une molécule donné dans
l'infrarouge et deux le nombre de
molécules présentes dans l'atmosphère et
c'est la fois l'autre qui donne ce qu'on
appelle le forçage radiatif c'est à dire
la fraction de flèche rouge vers le bas
ici qui est engendrée par la présence de
cette espèce dans l'atmosphère à la
concentration à laquelle elle est
présente alors je vais revenir
mon petit machin ici et on va continuer
la petite histoire c'est bon ca
s'affiche correctement
alors on va continuer dans le
médiatiquement incorrect vous avez tous
entendu la presse par les climatologues
ça n'existe pas il ya six ans aux
embranchements des géographes qu'ils
s'appellent des climatologues
mais en fait chez les physiciens il
n'existe pas de climatologues
il existe des tas de spécialité tout
ayant un domaine d'investigation bien
particulier et toute la grille et toute
la difficulté de cette affaire c'est que
la séance qui n'est qu'une juxtaposition
de spécialistes un besoin dans ce
domaine là de mettre tous les
spécialistes autour de la table pour
arriver à une vision d'ensemble d'un
phénomène ou d'un processus dans lequel
chacun détient une petite partie de la
vérité alors les physiciens ou
scientifiques qui vont intervenir dans
cette affaire
ils portent des noms qui sont par
ailleurs ni climatiquement correcte ni
climatiquement incorrect c'est les gens
qui font métier qui ont toujours fait et
ils ont commencé à regarder en
particulier dans le cadre de leurs
activités
cette affaire-là donc il ya des
astrophysiciens les astrophysiciens
s'intéresse à la manière dont l'énergie
solaire arrive sur terre et à la
fraction et à son flux vous allez avoir
des dynamicien d'atmosphère donc ça
c'est des gens qui s'intéressent à la
convection à grande échelle et aux
échanges d'énergie entre la surface et
les diverses couches de l'atmosphère
vous allez avoir besoin de chimistes de
l'atmosphère qu'on appelle aussi des
aéro log dont il y avait un éminent
représentant le regretté gérard mégi pas
très loin d'ici à jussieu qui est
quelqu'un qui a joué un rôle absolument
majeure dans la compréhension de la
diminution d'ozone stratosphérique
il ya malheureusement décédé il ya
quelques années vous avez besoin
d'océanographes par exemple vous avez
des gens à l'ifremer qui travaillent sur
ce genre de sujet vous avez besoin de
glaciologues dont jean jouzel est un
représentant
et ces gens là ils vont travailler sur
le
je dirais les climats du passé parce que
les calottes glaciaires sont de
merveilleuses archives climatique
vous allez avoir des vulcanologues
puisque le volcanisme comme je vous l'aï
dit tout à l'heure un flux sur la
formation du climat vous allez avoir des
géophysiciens vous allez avoir ce qu'on
appelle des biogéochimiste c'est à dire
des gens qui s'intéressent aux cycles
des éléments majeurs sur terre puisque
par exemple pour le carbone vous avez
communication entre dealers réservoir et
ça c'est typiquement quelque chose qui
va intéresser cette spécialité là vous
avez besoin de biologistes parce que la
végétation est couplé au système
climatique
on verra ça tout à l'heure et vous avez
maintenant besoin de gens qui sont
capables de raconter des choses sur la
manière dont vont se comporter les
hommes puisque les hommes sont devenus
un agent climatique en force en eux
aussi le système
donc vous voyez que il n'existe pas
climatologue au sens où il y aurait une
spécialité qui serait capable de
maîtriser toutes les connaissances
scientifiques qui sont nécessaires pour
avoir une vue d'ensemble sur le
phénomène
ça ne vous empêche pas par contre comme
ingénieur d'avoir cette vue d'ensemble
en allant chercher sur étagère les
résultats produits par toutes ces
disciplines scientifiques que soit dit
en passant
vous n'êtes ni capable de contester ni
capable de confirmer quand vous n'avez
pas vous même travaillé dans la
spécialité et scientifique en question
et publiée dans une revue scientifique à
comité de lecture c'est comme ça que ça
marche
en matière scientifique donc le métier
d'ingénieur a toujours été encore une
fois même s'il fait des mathématiques
financières a toujours été de prendre
sur étagère la science qui est produite
par la communauté compétentes de faire
la part des choses entre ce que la
communauté compétentes considèrent comme
acquis et ce qu'elle considère comme
faisant toujours l'objet de débats
et en ce qui concerne le climat elle se
donne la peine de faire ça puisque 800
plage un rapport du giec que pas un
journaliste n'a lui est pas un
économiste n'a lui est pas un chef
d'entreprise ne lui est pas un
responsable politique n'a lui donc c'est
et/ou et c'est cette matière là qui va
servir encore une fois à fonder derrière
les outils méthodes et techniques qui
vont permettre normalement d'augmenter
bien social
parce que là aussi
historiquement on a plutôt considéré qu
ingénieur était quelqu'un qui avait ça
dans son cahier des charges
donc encore une fois il n'existe pas il
n'existe pas une spécialité autonome qui
possède la totalité des connaissances
nécessaires là dessus ce qu'on appelle
le plus souvent des climatologues
ce sont des gens qui met en équation les
connaissances de ces gens là c'est à
dire qu'ils font un modèle dont je vous
parlerai tout à l'heure dans lequel il
importe les connaissances scientifiques
de tous leurs collègues qui ont
travaillé sur les divers compartiments
du système climatique et il essaye de
faire une représentation numérique de
cette affaire-là qu'ils tiennent à peu
près la route
donc en gros essaye de faire faillite
civile à tort sauf que c'est pas pour un
cockpit d'avion c'est pour le
fonctionnement de la machine climatique
alors au précieux je vous disais que il
faut que les sceptiques se met un peu au
goût du jour
de fait ils ont un siècle de retard
c'est en 1824 que fourier ça doit vous
dire un petit quelque chose parce que
c'est le même que celui dé transformer a
dit qu' il y avait un effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère
c'est en 1838 puis en 1860 quelque chose
que deux physiciens ont dit les
principales molécules c'est le gaz
carbonique
excusez moi le dioxyde de carbone et la
vapeur d'eau et enfin c'est en 1900 que
pour la première fois l'ordre de
grandeur a été cerné de la conséquence
qui suivrait le doublement de la
quantité de gaz carbonique dans
l'atmosphère par dont le dioxyde de
carbone mais sinon je vais jamais y
arriver
donc vous avez deux fois le co2 dans
l'atmosphère et monsieur hargneuse salue
aussi vous dire quelque chose
adiba en gros la température planétaire
s'équilibre +4 degrés par rapport à
aujourd'hui
et puis arenos avait déjà compris que
dans ce genre de processus ça
augmenterait plus vite au pôle contre un
pic et il avait également compris que
c'est intensifierait cycle de l'eau donc
les grandes lignes du petit dessin animé
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
était cerné au 19e siècle
ça c'était serré au 19e siècle ce qui
est plus récent c'est un d'avoir réussi
à modéliser tout ça pour essayer de voir
d'avoir une vision prospective et sans
la première tentative avec une feuille
de papier et un crayon c'est 1920 et
puis notre ami s'est rendu compte que
s'il essayait de remplacer les
microprocesseurs par des hommes il
allait y passer un petit moment
donc il a abandonné mais dès que le
premier ordinateur a été mis au coin
dès qu'il a été mis au point les
physiciens de l'époque sont allés
réalisé dessus le premier modèle de
simulation numérique du comportement
l'atmosphère donc le mariage entre
guillemets entre les informaticiens et
les physiciens pour essayer de bâtir ces
fameux modèles qui permettent d'avoir
une vision prospective de la faire ça ne
date pas de la semaine dernière de la
semaine dernière alors je vous disais
les gaz à effet de serre sont des gaz
qui ont adhéré d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge
alors quels sont ils eh bien les
principaux sont la vapeur d'eau et le
gaz carbonique
ensuite vous allez trouver par ordre
d'importance le méthane le protoxyde d
azote des halocarbures et l'ozone
alors dans cette affaire-là tous ces gaz
ont un cycle naturel sauf ceux là dont
quelques espèces sont présentes de
manière naturelle dans l'atmosphère mais
l'essentiel des espèces qu'on va trouver
aujourd'hui sont des créations humaines
il n'y avait il n'y avait pas ces
molécules hla en circulation dans
l'atmosphère avant l'ère industrielle
je vais revenir sur des essais d'hiver
c'est direct alors je vous disais tout à
l'heure qu'on n'avait pas le monopole de
l'effet de serre
non seulement on l'a pas mais on a un
concurrent qui nous enfoncent mais alors
d'une manière absolument spectaculaire
qui est venus venus à une température de
surface de l'ordre de 400 degrés de plus
400 420 450 les points d'échantillonnage
étant ce qu'ils sont je suis pas sûr que
quelqu'un sache ça au dixième de degré
près la différence avec la planète qui a
une température de surface moyenne de
l'ordre de 15 degrés alors une moyenne
c'est quoi c'est comme je vous disais la
dernière fois une double moyenne en fait
géographique et temporelle 1
donc c'est une intégrale double sur
l'année et sur la surface terrestre et
bien la différence de moyenne entre
vénus et la terre n'est pas due pour
l'essentiel à la plus grande proximité
deux venus du soleil ça toutes choses
égales par ailleurs et en faisant une
approximation avec le rayonnement du
corps noir vous arrivez au fait que
enfin que d'arriver au résultat que ça
augmenterait la température terrestre à
peu près 30 degrés de la mettre sur leur
de mettre à terre sur l'orbité de vénus
est la différence avec les 400 degrés
qui y sont pour de vrai c'est la
quantité de co2 que vous avez dans
l'atmosphère vénusienne l'atmosphère
vénusienne comporte à peu près 95 % de
co2 et de du coup au lieu d'avoir 40 ou
50 degrés à la surface de vénus vous
avez 400 de quelque chose c'est juste ça
la différence
il est assez vraisemblable que
l'atmosphère primitive de la terre
ressemblait beaucoup à celle de vénus et
au fil des années on a eu affaire à la
première pollution d'envergure à cause
des bactéries et ont séquestré le co2
présent dans l'atmosphère en le
transformant en calcaire pour
l'essentiel et pour une micro mais
vraiment micro par an kérogène et en
pétrole comme je vous ai expliqué ça la
dernière fois la quantité de gaz à effet
de serre présents dans l'atmosphère on
est aujourd'hui capable
et quand je dis on il s'agit de
disciplines scientifiques dont je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est à dire des
glaciologues et des aéro log capable de
l'as d'en cerner l'évolution sur des
échelles de temps très long alors la
manière dont ça se fait cette affaire
elle est très simple vous avez en
antarctique une zone de la planète où la
température est toujours négative qu'ils
s'agissent de l'hiver ou l'été donc
toutes les précipitations se font sous
forme de neige et cette neige ne font
jamais et ce qui se passe c'est que les
précipitations qui ont lieu année après
année finissent par se tasser sous leur
propre poids ou plus exactement les
précipitations qui ont lieu sous forme
de neige de l'année n prennent le poids
au bout de quelques siècles de quelques
mètres où quelques dizaines de mètres de
neige qui sont tombés par dessus et en
l'espace de quelques siècles
cette neige va donc progressivement se
passer et finir par se transformer en
glace sous l'effet de la pression
ce processus conduira emprisonné sous
forme de petites bulles mère qui
environnent les cristaux de neige
avec bien évidemment une comment dire un
anr qui a une valeur une composition
moyenne sur quelques siècles
1 c'est parce que l'air continue à
circuler entre les cristaux de neige
quand les bulls sont pas refermées et
vous allez donc retrouver la composition
moyenne de l'atmosphère avec ce genre de
processus de l'époque où la glace s'est
formée
donc vous allez faire des trous en
antarctique en forant jusqu'à quelques
kilomètres de profondeur et vous êtes
capable de retracer la composition
atmosphérique pour les espèces qui sont
chimiquement stable une fois enfermé
dans la bulle
ce qui est le cas du co2 sur des
périodes de temps extrêmement longue
actuellement il ya des informations qui
sont publiées jusqu'à il ya 800 milles
en 7 cents et quelques milliers d'années
dans lesquels du reste les européens en
général les français en particulier joue
un rôle de premier plan
donc vous avez ici en extraits de ces
mesures sur trois gaz à effet de serre
qui sont le dioxyde de carbone que vous
avez en rouge le méthane que vous avez
en noir au milieu et enfin protection en
bas là et le protoxyde d'azoté que vous
avez au milieu alors l'unité pour le
méthane est là et les unités pour le co2
est le dioxyde et le protoxyde d'azoté
sont là cd millionième pour le co2 et d
milliardième pour le côté protoxyde
d'azoté est ici ses limites pendant des
milliards de yens pour le méthane alors
vous voyez contre le début de l'ère
chrétienne et 17 cents vous avez des
fluctuations pour la concentration
atmosphérique de ces trois gaz bré il
s'agit de petites fluctuations et puis
arrive le début de la révolution
industrielle et vous voyez que les
concentrations de ces trois gaz augmente
de manière extrêmement significative est
aujourd'hui en fait toutes les analyses
qui peuvent être faites
tant sur la composition isotopique des
gaz que sur un certain nombre d'autres
d'autres paramètres ne propose pas
d'autres enfants propose un pardon ne
propose pas d'autre conclusion crédible
que c'est les activités humaines qui en
sont à l'origine
personne n'a réussi à expliquer ça
autrement
je vais vous donner un exemple l'air
accolade plus activement le carbone
qu'on trouve actuellement dans les
molécules de co2 dans l'air s'appauvrit
en carbone 14
or il se trouve que le seul réservoir de
carbone disponible sur terre qu'ils
soient exemple de carbone 14 c les
hydrocarbures qui sont présents sous
terre depuis trop longtemps pour qu'ils
aient conservé une fraction notable de
carbone 14 les émissions qui sont liés
soit la déforestation soit la
respiration des plantes et des animaux
soit au dégazage de co2 de l'océan
toutes choses dont je vous parlerai tout
à l'heure ne peuvent pas expliquer cet
appauvrissement de l'air en carbone 14
l'appauvrissement du co2 atmosphérique
en carbone 14
donc voilà par exemple un élément qui
indique qu' on ne sait pas expliquer
autrement qu'avec la combustion des
combustibles fossiles
cette caractéristique particulière du
co2 qu'on va trouver actuellement dans
la peau serre indépendamment de
l'augmentation de la concentration
donc vous avez aujourd'hui consensus sur
le fait que ce sont bien les activités
humaines qui sont à l'origine de cette
évolution
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu'on
pouvait remonter beaucoup plus loin dans
le temps donc voici un graphique c'est
pas possible de baisser la luminosité du
vidéoprojecteur là parce que c'est on
voit on voit pas grand chose
où la luminosité du parce que je pense
que la luminosité est laid c'est pas
tellement mais c'est le la lampe elle
même qui est qui est très c'est un peu
mieux au second secondes après ils vont
s'endormir
donc vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
retrace l'évolution de ces trois gaz à
des échelles de temps beaucoup plus
longue
alors faites attention ici vous démarrez
à -600 milan puis vous êtes à moins 500
viloin 400 milles et caetera et là vous
êtes à l'instant présent
alors vous voyez que le méthane comme le
co2 comme le protoxyde d'azoté sont des
gaz dont la concentration dans
l'atmosphère à varier de manière
parfaitement naturel parce qu'il ya cinq
cent mille ans les activités
industrielles de l'homme était un petit
peu plus réduite aujourd'hui mais
l'amplitude de ces variations ou la
rapidité de ces variations n'est en rien
comparable à ce qu'on a observé sur les
deux derniers siècles alors en ce qui
concerne le co2 l'amplitude de la
variation que j'ai rapporté ici sur
cette courbe est quelque chose qui est
comparable à ce qui s'est passé à des
échelles de temps ancien sauf que là
c'est allé à peu près 50 à 100 fois plus
vite que ce que la nature fait tout seul
entre guillemets dans un contexte
d'oscillations naturelle du système
climatique
en ce qui concerne le méthane non
seulement c'est aller beaucoup plus vite
que ce que la nature sait faire tout
seul mais là pour le coup l'amplitude de
la variation sur les deux derniers
siècles a été le triple de du maximum
qu'ils aient été qui étaient constatés
sur les 600 derniers milliers d'années
en ce qui concerne le protoxyde d'azoté
les marqueurs sur le marqueur est moins
facile
à reconstituer parce qu'il suffit pas
que le gaz soit présent dans la bulle
après il faut avoir l'instrumentation
qui permettent de mesurer la teneur en
gaz dans la bulle on sait faire ça avec
le méthane et on sait faire ça avec le
co2 plus dur avec le protoxyde d azote
mais vous avez aussi des variations dons
qui sont d'une amplitude qui a priori
est comparable à ce qu'on a constaté
récemment
sauf que récemment cette année là aussi
beaucoup plus vite voilà donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut retenir c'est
que pour le co2 c'est d'ampleur
comparable à ce que la nature fait tout
seul mais c'est allé beaucoup plus vite
et pour le métal c'est trop aujourd'hui
et ici
cette barre donne la concentration à
l'échelle de ce graphique évidemment la
concentration qui serait atteinte à la
fin du 21e siècle avec pour le trait
plein des émissions qui resterait
simplement constante et pour le trait
pointillés des émissions qui doublerait
voilà ce à quoi on arriverait à la fin
du 21e siècle avec les deux hypothèses
les deux hypothèses pardon que je viens
de vous évoquez c'est une autre manière
de dire que le monde du développement
durable entre guillemets ça ne sera pas
je reviendrai plus tard ça ne sera pas
et ça ne peut pas être un monde dans
lequel on se contente de laisser les
émissions en l'état n'est pas du tout ça
le monde du développement durable donc
il s'agit pas de laisser le monde en
l'état en sortant un rapport
développement durable et en disant ça y
est on a passé un grand coup de peinture
verte et maintenant le problème est
réglé
non c'est pas ça ça va être
nécessairement une diminution
extrêmement forte et extrêmement forte
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors là où le problème commence à se
compliquer c'est que une diminution très
forte des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour le moment c'est ça
s'apparente à des processus que les élus
ont du mal à vendre en démocratie vous
avez ici une courbe qui retrace
l'évolution des émissions de co2
provenant des combustibles fossiles pour
l'ensemble de la planète entre 18 ans
110 donc un petit peu après la deuxième
révolution industrielle et demi vous
constatez que en gros ça a suivi
l'évolution économique que au moment des
trente glorieuses vous voyez une
augmentation très forte des émissions
puisque entre l'après guerre là
945 part de 1945 on est on est on est
par là et 1970 c'est quelque chose ça a
été multiplié par deux à trois les
éditions donc en l'espace de quelque
chose d'extrêmement cours et vous riez
surtout que les moments où c'est allé
spontanément vers le gars sont associés
à des événements qui a priori n'était
pas spécialement sympathique pour les
gens qui les ont vécu plus ou moins
évidemment le choc pétrolier la guerre
fin pas exactement pareil il ya eu une
récession dans les années 90 au début
des années 90 au moment de la guerre du
golfe sais pas si vous vous en rappelez
il ya eu une très forte croissance
économique sur les cinq dernières années
qui s'est accompagnée d'une croissance
encore plus forte
les émissions de co2 encore plus forte
et par contre dans les années là aussi
vous étiez un peu petit pour qu'un
souvenir
dans les années qui ont suivi la chute
du mur de berlin les pays de l'est ont
connu une récession massive
mayrand massive et ça s'est accompagnée
d'une très forte contraction des
émissions de co2 qui dans certains pays
ont pu être jusqu'à diviser par 2 par an
et par personne
donc pour le moment les événements
spontanés qui marche très bien pour
faire baisser les émissions de co2 bah
c'est la guerre la récession c'est des
choses qui marche extrêmement bien
or ces émissions comme ceux c'est le
pendant de notre consommation d'énergie
fossile
elles sont condamnées à payer un jour un
jour viendra où elles baisseront comme
les combustibles fossiles sont issus
d'un stock fini je vous ai dit la
dernière fois que les mathématiques
s'appliquait et donc que leur
consommation tendra vers zéro à l'infini
donc les émissions de co2 tendre vers
zéro à l'infini donc quand quelqu'un
vous dit il n'est pas possible de
diviser les émissions par deux viols les
maths
non seulement c'est possible mais ça va
arriver
la seule question c'est quand et comment
mais il est absolument évident que ça va
arriver
absolument évident que ça variés le
propre d'un théorème normalement c'est
qu'il ne souffre pas d'exception
vous avez ici
et comme vous le savez les lois de la
physique à la différence des voix
humaine ne se laisse pas gueuler vous
avez ici les émissions de co2 de la
france depuis 1800 l'avalance de l'atome
de carbone sera au tour de 4 univers les
émissions de la france de 1800 jusqu'à
de ville et à la vous voyez qu'il ya
trois d'événements qui ont
significativement contribué à les faire
baisser
deux guerres et un programme nucléaire à
tout prendre le poste que je sais à peu
près ce que je préfère vous voyez que
encore une fois sur un pays qu'il a a
connu les dégâts sur son sol parce que
la couronne mondiale que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure n'a pas concerné
des dégâts sur le sol de tous les pays
et en particulier pendant cette période
là l'industrie américaine elle au
contraire elle a tourné à plein régime
donc pendant que nous on était en train
d'avoir les usines qui pétait les unes
derrière les autres
aux etats unis c'était plutôt inverse
ils étaient en train dé construire les
unes derrière les autres
donc l'effet net est moins marquée que
ce qu'on constate simplement pour la
france vous constaté aussi que donc un
programme nucléaire avait quelque chose
mené mené jusqu'au plus haut de la
fourchette puisqu'en france on est à 80%
nucléaire dans l'électricité ça un effet
parfaitement mesurables et mesurée en ce
qui concerne les émissions
toute la question est de savoir si c'est
assez ça sera juste la question est-ce
que c'est assez vous avez ici quelque
chose qui vous rapproche de ce que je
vous évoquez tout à l'heure qui est
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de
faire de la croissance économique sans
faire croître les émissions de co2 et
vous verrez avec une petite règle de
trois dans le cadre de secours que la
dématérialisation on peut vraiment se
poser la question de savoir si c'est
pour demain vous avez ici donc pour un
certain nombre de pays
le taux d'augmentation annuelle des
émissions de co2 par personne et le taux
d'augmentation annuelle du pib donc du
produit économique par personne sur 13
ans et vous constatez que dans tous les
pays déjà les deux sont positifs enfin
bon c'est un pro moment c'est pas une
preuve
et vous constatez surtout que dans un
certain nombre de pays ce qui n'est pas
une preuve non plus mais c'est quand
même une indication intéressante
le pib par personne croît moins vite que
les émissions de co2 par personne en dot
terme dans les pays qui sont en train de
s'industrialiser aujourd'hui à
l'exception de la chine et de l'inde
mais les statistiques économiques en
chine donne l'objet façon dont sont
l'objet d'innombrables débats parce que
dans un pays qui est en train de bouger
à cette vitesse avec un milliard
d'habitants
c'est pas toujours très facile de savoir
ce qui se passe exactement mais toujours
est il que dans le bon nombre de pays
vous constatez que les émissions de co2
vont plus vite que le produit économique
et en fait ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve au niveau mondial sur les cinq
dernières années où les émissions de co2
ont augmenté plus vite que le pib
mondial et ça c'est notamment le
résultat l'électrification au charbon
qui est en train de se développer à très
grande vitesse dans la majeure partie de
ces pays qui sont empruntés
industrialisés ça va encore plus vite
que l'accès aux transports
la raison pour laquelle la concentration
en gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère peut augmenter la boisson
c'est dû au fait que ces espèces sont
des aides aux docks les gaz à effet de
serre sont généralement ou en tout cas
celles qui nous intéressent des espèces
qui sont chimiquement très peu active
l'effet de serre est un processus
physiques il s'agit d'une molécule qui
absorbe la photo c'est pas de la chimie
donc c'est un processus physiques il n'y
a pas de dégradation
le dans une pollution ordinaire qui est
souvent une pollution chimique
quand la pollution se produit par nature
même le pôle ans disparaît à cette
occasion quand vous avez une réaction
chimique au moment où la pollution a
lieu la réaction va donc produire autre
chose que le composé initial en ce qui
concerne l'effet de serre la réaction
qui a lieu qui n'est pas une réaction
chimique mais une réaction physique j'ai
une molécule qui absorbent un photon ne
change pas ne modifie pas la présence de
la molécule qui exerce son effet donc
vous avez des constantes de temps sur
cet effet physique qui ne sont
absolument pas celle que vous avez sur
la pollution chimique et en particulier
vous n'avez pas des faits après le délai
est
vous n'avez pas épuration du polluant
quand il exerce son effet par ailleurs
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est que les molécules de gaz à effet
de serre sont pour l'essentiel des
molécules qui sont chimiquement près
stables une fois dans l'atmosphère et en
ce qui concerne la principale d'entre
elles qui est le co2 il n'existe pas il
est marginal un processus d'épuration
chimique du co2 de l'atmosphère
les deux processus de retrait à des
échelles de temps qui nous intéresse à
l'échelle du siècle du co2 ou la
décennie du co2 de l'atmosphère
il y en a deux et deux seulement c'est
la dissolution du co2 dans l'eau
océanique et l'absorption par les
plantes dans le cadre d'une réaction
photo chimiques et parachimiques tout
court 1
tous les gens qui essayent de faire
pousser du cannabis chez eux ils savent
qu'il faut de la lumière si on baisse
juste le machin dans un placard ça
marche pas donc il faut un photon donc
vous avez besoin d'une réaction
photo chimiques ça n'est pas une
réaction chimique il n'existe pas de
réactions chimiques permettant d'épurer
le co2 d'atmosphère il n'existe pas plus
de réactions chimiques permettant des
purées protoxyde d azote de l'atmosphère
le seul gaz à effet de serre qui peut
être épurée de manière si vite que
l'atmosphère c'est le méthane qui fait
l'objet d'une réaction avec les radicaux
hydroxyles qui les purs un peu plus vite
que les au gaz à effet de serre vous
avez ici un graphique qui matérialisent
c'est très faible réactivité chimique et
gaz à effet de serre et qui se lit comme
suit vous avez en ordonner le forçage
radiatif c'est à dire en fait là le
surplus de concentration c'est
exactement ça la nar et l'autre étant
proportionnel qui est occasionnée par
une tonne de gaz à effet de serre
larguée à l'instant zéro
enfin comme celle aux gars rythmique en
ami 01 puisque loeb 2 0 on savait qu'on
a des problèmes et ici vous avez les
faits résiduelles au cours du temps où
le forçage résiduelles conduite en 2 7
tonnes qui est largué à l'instant zéro
dans ce que dit ce graphique c'est que
vous larguiez une tonne de co2 à
l'instant zéro au bout d'un an
l'effet résiduelle est toujours le même
en d'autres termes cet automne est
toujours là au bout de dix ans l'effet
résiduelle est toujours le même donc
cette tonne est toujours là au bout d'un
siècle
vous avez commencé en enlever 10 ou 20%
le reste est toujours là et il faut
attendre de l'aide du millier d'années
que vous ayez gagné un facteur 100 sur
la concentration de 7 tonnes à fonc
lentement sur la fraction de 7 tonnes
qui est toujours dans l'air donc il n'en
reste plus que 1 % on va dire c'est
cette caractéristique l'a absolument
fondamental absolument fondamental qui
explique une large partie de tout ce que
je vais vous raconter maintenant et en
particulier de l'inertie de l'évolution
que nous avons mise en route il n'existe
pas et ça c'est quelque chose
d'absolument capitale il n'existe pas de
notion de remise en état du système
climatique
ça n'existe pas donc ce que la
génération de mes parents a fait est ce
que ma génération a fait pourrait faire
ce que vous voulez vous le des frais
temps vous ne devrez pas vous pourrez
contribuer à ce qu'on en rajoute moins
je l'espère
ma génération aussi du reste devra s'y
mettent rapidement et la génération de
mes parents encore plus rapidement
mais pour ceux qui ont vu emmanuelli
c'est pas gagné d'avancé mais par contre
une chose est absolument certaine
une chose est absolument certaine c'est
que vous ne désirez pas ce qui a été
fait ou ne défraie pas et c'est dû
encore une fois non pas à des
considérations idéologiques
c'est dû à ses caractéristiques
physiques des gaz à effet de serre qui
est qu'ils n'ont pas de processus
d'épuration rapide une fois qu'on les
met dans l'atmosphère par ailleurs vous
voyez que le forçage radiatif liée à
l'introduction d'une tonne de gaz à
effet de serre au moment où on
l'introduit est très variable
par exemple au moment où on introduit la
tonne vous avez c'est en logarithmique
en vertical aussi vous avez un rapport
qui n'est pas loin d'être de 1 à 100
doit être de 1,81 truc comme ça entre
une tonne de métal et une tonne de co2
par contre au bout de dix ans vous avez
le méthane qui a commencé à ces purées
alors que le co2 non et au bout d'un
siècle
votre méthane vous voyez qu'il a perdu 4
ordre de grandeur en ce qui concerne
serre présents dans l'atmosphère alors
que le co2 est toujours présent à peu
près à la même concentration que celle
que vous avez créé au moment où vous
avez injecté boston
ça veut dire que si vous voulez comparer
les gaz entre eux vous avez un problème
qui est de savoir quel est l'étalon de
mesure que vous prenez est ce que vous
prenez le forçage radiatif instantanée
au moment où vous larguer votre temps
ou est ce que vous prenez un effet
cumulé ce qui revient à faire
l'intégrale de cette courbe en
l'arrêtant à un horizon de temps donné
et la réponse qu'on rapportait les
physiciens pour le moment c'est de
choisir
l'intégrale de la courbe arrêté à un
horizon de temps donné il ya donc
quelque chose qui sert à mesurer les gaz
à effet de serre qui est ce qu'on
appelle le prg en français pouvoir de
réchauffement global ou en anglais le
global warming potential gwp si vous
avez une recherche à faire sur le
pouvoir de réchauffement global d'un gaz
sont google je vous conseille d'utiliser
l'acronyme anglais parce que c'est la
littérature scientifique et en anglais
dans des bourgs plus de chance de
trouver et qui est tout simplement le
rapport des intégrales du forçage
radiatif d une même quantité de gaz à un
horizon de temps donnée qui en général
est arrêté un siècle
mais vous voyez que cet horizon de temps
il a un effet déterminant sur le rapport
entre les deux puisque si vous prenez
par exemple le co2 et le méthane avouer
que le rapport des intégrales arrêté à
10 ans ne va pas être le même que le
rapport des intégrales arrêté au siècle
parce que la durée de vie dans
l'atmosphère de ces deux espèces n'est
pas la même s'ils ont la même durée de
vie c'est même un port s'ils n'ont pas
la même durée dit ça change au cours du
temps si vous avez une espèce qui vit
plus longtemps que le co2 dans
l'atmosphère plus l'horizon de temps et
lointain et plus le prg est important si
c'est vous avez une espèce qui vivent
moins longtemps que le co2 dans
l'atmosphère c'est l'exact inverse
plus votre espèce à un horizon de temps
enfin une durée de vie courte dans
l'atmosphère est plus le prg diminue au
conduit avec l'horizon de temps qui
s'éloigne donc le prg à 20 ans du
méthane par exemple est de l'ordre de 60
alors que le prg a 100 ans et de 25 et
ça traduit le fait que l'essentiel de
l'effet du méthane s'exerce dans un
horizon de temps court par rapport à
celui du co2 alors ça peut vous paraître
technique ce truc là il n'empêche que si
un jour dans votre métier vous avez
besoin de prendre et vous en aurez
besoin de prendre
avoir une réflexion sur les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de l'entité où vous
vous trouvez si vous n'avez pas des
talents de comparaison permettant de
savoir si avec 100 euros ou au mieux
économiser 1 kg de méthane 20 kg de co2
vous serez pas capable de faire votre
métier et pour savoir s'il vaut mieux
économiser l'un que l'autre
il faut avoir cet étalon de mesure et il
faut savoir ce qui est pertinent comme
horizon de temps alors pour le moment
l'horizon de temps qui a été choisi
c'est un siècle c'est celui là peut-être
qui variera parce qu'on se rend compte
que le méthane finalement il faut s'en
débarrasser plus vite que ça ici vous
avez la contribution à l'accroissement
annuel du forçage radiatif des divers
gaz à effet de serre au cours du temps
il ya des espèces qui avait un rôle très
important et notamment les cfc
il ya quelques années et vous voyez en
particulier ici une espèce qui est le
cfc 12 que vous voyez là et bien dans
les années 80 les émissions annuelles de
cfc représentait un milliard de tonnes
équivalent carbone alors que le co2
stricto sensu représentait 3 milliards
de tonnes équivalent carbone
donc au moment où on émettait de manière
massive des cfc les émissions de cfc
pouvait représenter jusqu'à un tiers ou
simplement l'accroissement annuel du
stock atmosphérique résultant des
émissions pouvaient être seulement de
1/3 en ce qui concerne le cfc par
rapport aux émissions de co2 donc et
c'est ch et sont toujours là les cfc
qu'on a et vit dans les années 50 60 et
70 sont toujours là ils sont partis ils
vont mettre des décennies ou des siècles
avant de partir si vous faites
maintenant une comparaison des effets
naturels et artificiels entre guillemets
au forçage radiatif de l'atmosphère
depuis un siècle
un peu plus d'un siècle vous obtenez ce
diagramme ce diagramme il est donc la
représentation des ordres de grandeur de
ce qui fait varier le climat entre
guillemets à l'échelle du siècle selon
la cause de variation à laquelle vous
vous intéressez donc vous voyez par
exemple que le soleil fait varier le
climat à l'échelle du siècle
sauf que les variations du système
induite par la variabilité solaire et en
particulier le fameux cycle de onze ans
son petit comparé aux autres causes de
variations par exemple volcanisme
et surtout l'accumulation de gaz à effet
serre dans l'atmosphère donc en gros la
réponse à la question qui est ce que
l'homme est en train de devenir le
facteur dominant de variation du système
en ce qui concerne les températures et
les précipitations
ça commence tout juste par contre en ce
qui concerne les tâches d'avant c'est à
dire le forçage radiatif de l'atmosphère
là la réponse est sans ambages oui à la
réponse est sans ambages oui et nous
n'avons pas vu et nous sommes encore
très loin d'avoir vu la totalité des
effets induits par le surplus de gaz à
effet de serre qu'on a déjà vu dans
l'atmosphère donc la facture on n'a pas
encore payé
je vous disais que les gaz à effet de
serre naturel c'est essentiellement de
la vapeur d'eau et du co2 voici le
diagramme qui le matérialise avec du
coup quelque chose qui va avoir beaucoup
d'importance qui est le couplage entre
les deux parce que vos ajouter un peu de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
du coup les basses couches de
l'atmosphère vont voir leur température
augmenter
du coup leur capacité d'emport en vapeur
d'eau pour augmenter puisque vous savez
que la quantité de vapeur d'eau que peut
contenir l'atmosphère s'accroît avec sa
température et du coup l'effet de serre
dû à la vapeur d'eau se renforce donc là
vous avez ce qu'on appelle une
rétroaction positive ou une
amplification qui fait que le système va
avoir tendance à finir en choquera
converger mais le système dans la loire
tendance dans un premier temps à
amplifier la perturbation que nous lui
apportons
si on regarde quels sont les gaz à effet
de serre d'origine anthropique
c'est à dire humaine voilà quel est le
supplément de forçage radiatif par gaz
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que si je
prends une photo de ma flèche rouge vers
le bas dans l'animation je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure il ya deux siècles
et que je reprends la photo de cette
flèche rouge vers le bas aujourd'hui est
bien la différence entre les deux photos
le supplément de flèche rouge vers le
bas il est due pour moitié au gaz
carbonique
il est dû pour 15 % environ au méthane
il est du surplus de gaz carbonique au
surplus de méthane évidemment il est du
pur 5% au surplus de protoxyde d'azoté
pour un peu plus de 10% au surplus dalo
carbure c'est à dire toutes les
molécules qui sont de type carbone
allogènes hydrogène
c'est ça qu'on appelle des halocarbures
ça peut être saturé en halo
ça peut être juste avec du fluor juste
avec du chlore avec un mélange de brome
de chlore et fluor enfin voilà la
créativité humaine est sans limite
c'est ça qu'on appelle les halocarbures
et ce surplus dalo carbure
c'est surtout aujourd'hui les c s est
accumulée pendant les années où on en
est là et c'est beaucoup moins ce qu'on
aimait aujourd'hui et enfin vous avez un
surplus de 10 % de cette flèche rouge
vers le bas qui est due à l'augmentation
de la concentration de fond en ozone en
ozone est une espèce civique qui ces
purs très vite quand on arrête d'en
créer mais il ya une eau bien quand même
eu une augmentation de la concentration
de fond en ozone parce que les espèces
les précurseurs de l'ozone
ce qui permet à l'ozone d'apparaître
dans l'atmosphère e on n'arrête pas d'en
émettre de plus en plus si on regarde
maintenant n'ont pas donc ça en gros
c'est l'effet du stock accumulé depuis
un siècle et demi de siècle c'est
l'effet du stock accumulé ça maintenant
si vous regardez la contribution
annuelle à l'accroissement du stock
voilà ce que ça donne 56% de cette
contribution vient des énergies fossiles
je vous ai pas mis le troisième chiffres
après la virgule donc retenu une grosse
moitié parce que tout ça est valable
avec des barres des erreurs
significatives 20% plus ou moins quelque
chose plus ou moins dix ans fait est
liée à la déforestation
alors la déforestation l'essentiel de ce
processus dans le monde vient de quelque
chose de très simple
des gens ont une population qui croît
ils ont donc besoin de surfaces
agricoles en quantité croissante dont
qu'ils en prennent là où pousse des
arbres qui coupent les arbres et vole
c'est ça l'essentiel du processus de
déforestation aujourd'hui avec en plus
quelques effets de bord qui peuvent
venir l'accroître ou le déplacer un
premier effet de bord c'est par exemple
les européens avant de manger du boeuf
donc les brésiliens augmente les
pâturages pour faire paître d2 et les
pâturages il est prête sur la forêt ou
bien les européens vol de l'huile de
palme pour m ou bien dans les biscuits
ou bien dans les réservoirs de voitures
et à ce moment les indonésiens qui sont
pas fous ils coupent de la forêt et ils
plantent des paniers à huile à la place
alors les palmiers à huile sur une forêt
sauf que c'est quand même une forêt qui
a moins de carbone que la forêt primaire
qui a dont elle a pris la place donc le
l'essentiel de l'accroissement ou la
diminution des surfaces boisées
est le fruit d'une pression agricole
avec une petite composante qui à la
recherche de bois de feu qui est
particulièrement significative en
afrique notamment sur le pourtour des
villes donc tout ça et le bois de feu
bah c'est du carbone qui était sur pied
qui va finalement le transfert donc tout
la déforestation est quelque chose qui
contribue de manière significative parce
que il y avait du stock sur pied et où
le transformer en stock en l'air et vous
avez également une fois que vous avez
fini
enfin vous avez coupé les arbres une
perte de carbone du sol car un sol de
forêt et plus riches en carbone qu'un
seul agricoles et en particulier le
labourage va exposer l'humus qui
contient du carbone à l'oxygène de l'air
et de ce fait créer un flux de carbone
des sols vers l'atmosphère
c'est un flux non linéaire mais qui
perdure un certain nombre de dizaines
d'années après qu'on ait déforester donc
vous avez là un une composante qu'ils
peuvent pour certains pays supérieure à
la composante énergie fossile c'est par
exemple le cas au brésil
c'est par exemple le cas en indonésie ça
peut être le cas dans un certain nombre
de pays d'afrique aussi je connais pas
les chiffres par coeur donc vous avez un
flux qui est très significatif à
l'échelle de la planète
le méthane vous allez voir d'où il vient
donc les émissions de méthane
aujourd'hui c'est 15 % 2 des émissions
anthropiques de gaz à effet de serre
protoxyde d'azoté à peu près 7 et vous
étiez gaz fluorés dont les halocarbures
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus qu'un gros %
alors que dans le stock accumulé ces et
10% et c'est 10 % parce que fut une
époque où les émissions dalo carbure
c'était beaucoup plus que 10% des
émissions humaines
c'est à cause de ça que l'on a
aujourd'hui 10 % dans forçage c'est
simplement un concert dans les émissions
annuelles
oui si vous avez quatre ans je vais pas
m'étendre là dessus c'était juste pour
vous montrer que la concentration de
fois en ozone avait augmenté partout là
vous avez les émissions de co2 par
hydrocarbures partie d'énergie pour la
partie qui vient évidemment d'énergie
fossile donc aujourd'hui 40 % des
émissions mondiales de co2 viennent du
charbon et 40% du pétrole donc le co2 ça
n'est pas que les voitures ou pas que
les voitures les centrales électriques à
charbon
c'est plus important que les voitures à
l'échelle mondiale plus important
et vous avez 20 % qui viennent du gaz
qui encore une fois je le rappelle n'est
pas une énergie propre au regard du
climat
c'est une énergie - salle par unité
d'énergie que le charbon ou le pétrole
mais c'est la dose qui fait le poison et
ça n'est pas une énergie propre et en
plus vous avez des fuites dans
l'exploitation du gaz naturel et il se
trouve que un atome de méthane a eu
molécules de méthane par dont on
considère que c'est équivalent à 25 fois
exactement 1 kg de méthane c'est
équivalent à 25 kg de co2 donc il suffit
de quelques pourcents suite de méthane
dans le système pour rendre le gaz
naturel aussi polluant entre guillemets
que le charbon et le débat sur le taux
exact de fuites de méthane dans
l'exploitation du gaz naturel est un
débat qui n'est pas près de se terminer
et où très peu de gens ivres clair pour
être vous avez ici les émissions de co2
par personne provenant de l'énergie
fossile et leur évolution entre 1990 et
2003 j'ai pas de montre d'angers
laquelle rien il est d'accord parfait on
va jouer montre encore de trucs et puis
on s'arrête ici vous avez les émissions
de co2 par personne
depuis fera donc avec la différence 1990
2003 alors vous voyez un certain nombre
de choses là aussi qui peuvent
éventuellement contrarier ce que le
journal vous raconte sur la réputation
écolo de tel ou tel pays
vous voyez par exemple ici l'autriche
souvent citée en exemple dans les pays
qui ont une conscience environnementale
forte va c'est peut-être vrai qu un tas
de sujets et je n'ai absolument rien
contre les autrichiens
en attendant si vous prenez le résultat
brut qui nous intéresse qui et combien
de co2 par personne et par an entre 1990
et 2003 ça augmente et vous prenez le
danemark qui là aussi est un pays que
des journalistes français aiment
beaucoup cité en exemple ils ont pu
installer toutes les éoliennes qui
voulait
voilà le résultat et c'est pas étonnant
quand on connaît les ordres de grandeur
nos amis finlandais aussi on suit
souvent l'énormité des rats la france
est significativement plus bas et il ya
une raison à cela
ici vous avez les allemands qui ont
effectivement significativement diminué
depuis 1990 mais il ya eu un une
composante absolument majeur dans cette
histoire c'est la réunification de
l'allemagne puisque dans la
réunification parce que 107 à périmètre
constant donc en fait c'est les
émissions des anciens allemands de l'est
et les émissions des anciens allemand
l'ouest et leur évolution au cours du
temps
si on avait pris juste l'allemagne de
l'ouest vous auriez pas du tout cette
évolution les grecs ou augmenter les
italiens ont augmenté les japonais ont
augmenté et polonais ont un peu diminué
parce qu'ils ont une récession et russes
ont un peu diminué parce qu'ils ont eu
une récession les espagnols ça c'est la
traduction de la croissance économique
très forte de l'espagne des 15 dernières
années
ce qui soit dit en passant pose un vrai
problème parce que si le projet de
l'union européenne c'est de faire en
sorte que tous les états qui rentrent
actuellement se met à avoir le niveau de
consommation des français ou d'un
allemand à mon avis il va graver des
illusions avant ma vie va y avoir des
désillusions
je pense qu'on s'apprête à vivre à cause
de ce que je vous ai raconté la dernière
fois sur le stock de combustible fossile
accessible donc je je je je demande à
voir à quoi ressemble le projet qui est
compatible avec les grandeurs physiques
dont nous sommes en fin de partie voilà
la suisse a un peu baissé mais les
suisses il ya une bonne partie des
émissions qui n'ont pas lieu chez eux
donc c'est très difficile d'interpréter
ces statistiques de manière correcte le
crâne ça c'est le résultat de la
récession le royaume uni c'est assez peu
de partie le résultat du passage au gaz
d'une partie des centrales électriques
ils continuent à avoir une des plus
grosses centrales à charbon d'europe 1 à
brax mai
je passais à l'électricité les
etats-unis dont congolais entre 1990 et
2003 à peu près tout le monde a augmenté
sauf récession qui est venu aider les
gens et vous constatez que si c'est pas
pour faire du chauvinisme de base mais
si on prend comme critère les émissions
de co2 par personne et par an en valeur
absolue bien qu'on ait encore énormément
d'efforts à faire puisqu'il va falloir
diviser sa part 4 on n'est pas
nécessairement ceux qui doivent s'auto
flageller le plus fort aujourd'hui
alors il faut que c'est le résultat de
choix historique qui ne devait
absolument rien à la préoccupation
climatique mais le fait brut encore une
fois c'est que si ce qui nous intéresse
peu importe le moyen c'est de faire
baisser les émissions de co2 il n'est
pas dit que les options qu'on a pris
jusqu'à maintenant étaient les plus
idiotes
bon je vais m'arrêter là on va chacun
faire un pas vers l'autre donc on va
limiter la pause à 10 minutes et je vous
propose de reprendre à 10h20 a longtemps
maintenant